счастье состоит из четырёх компонентов
мы сами себе в голове создаем тюрьму
если у вас не будет хотя бы одного
компонента то у вас не будет счастье о
какой любви можно говорить если вы не
знаете как устроить свои бытовые вопросы
[музыка]
урок 3
планирование и счастья есть такое
изречение писателя и философа ричарда
баха я надеюсь вы читали его книгу там
чайка по имени джонатан ливингстон там
ну какие-то философские у него книжки
как вот это американский писатель и
философ так он сказал вам никогда не
дается мечта без ресурсов и сил для ее
осуществления
если у вас есть мечта она просто так не
приходит значит у вас есть и будут силы
и ресурсы для того чтобы и осуществить
вот поверьте мне из моего опыта это
жизни действительно работает так ваша
задача правильно и эффективно
использовать существующие и будущее
ресурсы и силы для достижения ваших
целей
это уже ваша задача определение счастья
мы будем проходить в последующих уроках
а пока вкратце лишь скажу счастье
состоит из четырёх компонентов
первый компонент счастья это
безопасность который комп этот компонент
свою очередь состоит из физической
безопасности экономической безопасности
и юридической безопасности
второй компонент счастья это здоровье
которые в свою очередь состоит из
физического здоровья психического или
душевного здоровья ментального здоровья
третий компонент счастье это свобода
которая в себя включает физическую
свободу
юридическую свободу экономическую
свободу и ментальную свободу и вот здесь
я дам небольшое пояснение мы к этому еще
вернемся в
уроки про счастье ну вкратце чтобы
понимали вот например
что такое физическая свобода она вам
наверно совсем ясно это когда вас
закроют куда-то в каком-то помещении
дают не дают выйти это ограничение вашей
физической свободы а если вы хотите
полететь в сша и у вас нету визы
то у вас нету юридической свободы или вы
хотите прокатиться на ferrari
а у вас нету прав у вас нет юридической
свободы если вы хотите купить ferrari а
у вас нету денег у вас нету
экономической свободы хотя вроде и право
есть
или вы хотите полетит сша у вас и виза
есть и желание и физическая свобода есть
а экономическая свобода купить билет
нету ментальная свобода вот ментальная
свобода это основной ограничители любого
человека мы сами себе создаем барьеры
когда надо у кого-то что-то попросить
буду ему это неудобно
моя что он подумает а что подумают
другие люди а вдруг он занятой человек а
вдруг у меня пошлет и так далее так
далее мы сами себе в голове создаем
тюрьму из-за стены которые мы боимся
выйти
может документальная свобода ну и
четвертый компонент счастье это любовь
любовь к людям и любовь к делу
любовь к людям к своей жене и детям
родственникам друзьям и так далее и
любовь к делу это то дело которое
придает вообще смысл всей вашей жизни
так вот к чему это я говорю если у вас
не будет хотя бы одного компонента
которая из которого состоит счастья то у
вас не будет счастья а как вы можете
достичь например экономической свободы
если у вас нет эффективной системы
планирования как вы сохраните
психическое здоровье
если вы за дерганые вечными проблемами
аврала my и стрессами о какой
безопасности может идти речь если вы не
знаете что будет дальше как жить дальше
что делать на случай неблагоприятного
развития ситуаций о какой любви можно
говорить если вы не знаете как устроить
свои бытовые вопросы вы же знаете
большинство браков распадается в первые
годы
именно из-за бытовых неурядиц лучше
всего для полноценного обеспечения
счастья а возможно что это даже
единственный способ подходит технология
которую мы рассматриваем в этих курсах
путем нахождения своего
и тягой который мы рассмотрели в
январских курсах путем правильного
планирования планирование и счастья это
как вы убедитесь попозже имеет
непосредственную связь
[музыка]